in this week's morning rounds a look at
the future of Medicine and that includes
some incredible new therapies that make
use of our own living cells these
cutting-edge medical topics and more are
the focus of the new book cells are the
new cure and we are joined by co-author
and medical correspondent for our New
York station WCBS dr. max Gomez doc good
morning good morning so let's first
start with stem cells I think some
people have a passing familiarity with
them but what I think most folks don't
know is their different kind exactly
there's a lot of confusion the ones that
most people are know about are embryonic
stem cells and they're the ones that
have some moral and ethical baggage
associated because usually in order to
use them you've got to destroy an embryo
so that's what people have a problem
with of course but we also have adult
stem cells we've got stem cells probably
in every tissue in our body that we
found brain heart muscle even fat fat
has a lot of something for useful right
and then there's there's what we call
IPS cells where you can take some adult
cells usually from the skin do a little
genetic manipulation and turn them into
things that look like embryonic stem
cells so you really don't need to go to
embryonic to do a lot of things that we
can do with stem cells another hot topic
is in the field of gene editing and you
go into detail on one of the tools
called CRISPR what is this exactly
CRISPR is really exciting because it's a
much more accurate and efficient way of
editing DNA the genome if you've got a
mutation a bad gene in there you can go
in snip that out and then insert the
right copy of the corrected gene if you
will but the problem of course is you
don't know exactly what that's going to
do yeah genes often have a lot of
different effects and you can get
different effects that you're that are
unintended well I'm not raised as a host
of ethical concerns too because once
that gene is edited it is passed on
through the generations right if you do
that in what they what we call germ cell
lines meaning eggs or sperm those get
passed on and now it's a permanent
change everybody down the human race for
the human race or everybody in that
particular no from that particular
person has that problem you can get
these what we call off
it affects his genes often have not just
one effect but they have multiple ones
or you've edited other genes that you
didn't need to edit so you're not really
sure so there's a lot of potential
problems with that and of course there's
the issue of can we use gene editing
CRISPR to do things like what we want a
blue-eyed blonde babe right right big
you know 7-foot tall so they'll be in
the NBA or something like that
we don't really know how to do that yet
but you know that's that's potentially
just last month IMAX the FDA approved a
cell based gene therapy it's just the
second time they've done that how big a
deal is this this is really huge it is
potentially a cure the c-word that
doctors don't like to use very often for
a couple of cancers this was for
non-hodgkins lymphoma it's been done for
leukemia no you take it's called car
t-cells you take your own immune cells
do a little genetic manipulation with it
and then put those back in now those
immune cells know how to recognize the
cancer cells and they go after the
cancer cells and kill them off and
immunotherapy seems to be the forefront
here it's just we're at the tip of the
iceberg as it were right absolutely
immunotherapy is really the hottest area
in cancer therapy right now and it's all
versions of using your own cells we can
take used drugs to take the brakes off
the immune system we can use drugs to
strip the Harry Potter cloak of
invisibility off of cancer so that the
immune system can recognize it and then
we can take these cells the immune cells
manipulate them so they know how to
recognize cancer and go after the cancer
cell we're just at the tip of the
iceberg with that but it's really
exciting it is exciting stuff all of
many questions
the book is cells are the new cure dr.
max Gomez thanks for being with us thank
you